l'impression qui a rien qui peut freiner
la croissance économique au québec qui
après un début d'année déjà vigoureux où
la croissance tournait autour de 3%
ça s'est encore accélérée et progression
de 3,6 pour cent en rythme annualisé au
troisième trimestre à faire le point
avec hélène bégin économiste chez
desjardins on la retrouve dans nos
studios de québec montfort madame déjà %
madame salerno clairement le québec sort
du lot si on regarde les provinces
canadiennes on va vous présenter tout de
suite un graphique qui le montre on à la
croissance du québec celle du canada
c'est trois fois plus vigoureux dans
l'ensemble du québec le comparativement
au pays
est-ce que c'est spectaculaire un écart
comme celui là oui c'est tout à fait ça
c'est rarement vu par le passé et
l'accélération de l'économie du québec
survient à un moment où celle de
l'amérique du nord et plutôt en
ralentissement
tout comme la plupart des pays
industralisés dans le monde donc une
croissance qui s'accélère à trois et
demi pour cent et plus alors que les
autres perdent la vitesse c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment particulier oui on est un
cas à part
est ce que ça vous étonne ben en fait ça
fait quand même à trois années
consécutives que le québec connaît une
excellente performance une croissance
économique au delà de deux ans et demi
pour cent qui peut aller jusqu'à 3%
donc cette année on veut atteindre près
3% c'est nettement mieux que le canada
l'ontario la colombe et années que la
croissance économique va être inférieure
à 2%
donc c'est certain qu'il ya plusieurs
facteurs qui fait en sorte que
l'économie du québec se porte bien
notamment pour le troisième trimestre
notamment les dépenses des ménages
continue de progresser quand même un bon
rythme le secteur résidentiel connaît un
essor a quand même depuis un bon moment
et là vous parler d'immobilier madame
bégin on a un tableau justement qu'ils
montent parce que le secteur du mobilier
au québec est en croissance comme celui
au canada mais on va pouvoir le voir sur
la courbe c est beaucoup plus stable
c'est plus constant à l'augmentation au
québec où effectivement c'est que au
québec ça fait quand même un plusieurs
années que le marché immobilier se porte
bien et des hausses de prix autour de 5
% depuis maintenant trois ans et par le
passé au canada dans certaines grandes
villes notamment
à couvert et toronto on a connu des
hausses de prix très très
impressionnante en 10 et 15 % pour
certaines années ça fait en sorte que
les prix de l'immobilier au québec qui
ont augmenté mais le niveau est resté
beaucoup plus ferme que ce qu'on a
ailleurs dans certaines villes par
exemple pour la grande région
métropolitaine de montréal
le prix moyen est au tour de 415 mille
dollars à toronto c'est près du double
alors ça fait en sorte que des prix
lorsqu'ils sont moins élevés ça donne
quand même une marge de manoeuvre
supplémentaire aux ménages
il ya une part moins importante des des
revenus des ménages qui sont bons dans
le paiement des hypothèques air au
québec et ça fait en sorte que le mal
marché ma vidéo québec a été moins
sensible à toute la réglementation
fédérale notamment s'est resserrée au
fil du temps notamment 2018 que provoque
une correction importante est également
au niveau provincial en ontario et en
colombie-britannique la taxe sur les
investisseurs étrangers a également fait
mal donc comme les prix sont moins
élevés au québec
ça fait en sorte que le marché
immobilier accaparent une part moins
élevé des ménages même que si de notre
côté on trouve que c'est quand même
beaucoup plus qu'auparavant mais ça même
quand même une certaine je dirais une
certaine dynamique qui qui nous épargne
un peu les dents sont les corrections
qu'ont connu à vancouver et toronto et
surtout que le marché de montréal 6 1 à
6 h il n'est pas surévalué du moins pour
le moment là on parlait être surchauffe
et un madame déjà on parle de surchauffe
tout à fait c'est différent la
surchauffe survient lorsqu'on a une
forte croissance de prix et que le
nombre de maisons à vendre est
insuffisante pour combler la demande
mais pour la surévaluation c'est
vraiment lorsque les facteurs
fondamentaux tels que l'emploi les taux
d'intérêt la démographie est nettement
déconnecté de la hausse des prix est bon
moria jusqu'à maintenant tous ces
éléments là seront là et ça se sait
supporté par des facteurs fondamentaux
donc le marché n'est pas surévalué comme
l'était vancouver et toronto
il ya quelques années donc c'est
différent donc un marché de l'immobilier
qui stimule l'économie mais
évidemment plusieurs autres secteurs
dans votre étude on signale le fait que
diversification et six industriels
peut-être même plus forte qu'ailleurs
oui tout à fait comme par le passé le
québec quand même un diversification au
niveau de ses exportations au niveau de
ces secteurs
beaucoup de beaucoup plus de haute
technologie qu'auparavant donc
évidemment on a vu tout à l'heure
l'économie canadienne qui avait connu
certaines difficultés cette année avec
des trimestres de faible croissance qui
était associé a entre autres aux
difficultés du secteur pétrolier qui a
arrêté certaines provinces et également
aux marchés immobiliers qui s'est remis
d'une correction donc le québec n'a pas
être affectée par le marché immobilier
en fait qu'elle continue à avoir une
quand même une belle croissance
un secteur pétrolier qui est peu présent
donc ça fait déjà deux facteurs qui nous
permet de d'abord une meilleure
performance que le canada est
inévitablement ça a une influence sur
les finances publiques
on a un graphique qui va vous montrer à
quel point ç'a eu une incidence sur le
solde budgétaire avant 2015 c'était plus
difficile et là vous parliez de trois
années de forte croissance
on voit les bandes qui s'élève au même
rythme donc ça veut dire des surplus ça
à québec où effectivement faut dire que
depuis quelques années le contexte
fiscal et budgétaire complètement a
changé pour le québec
on était plusieurs années à se demander
si on va redresser les finances
publiques c'est maintenant chose faite
donc on est passé d'une aire de déficit
à une heure de surplus et ça permet dans
le fond de d'avoir une meilleure marge
de manoeuvre pour le gouvernement du
québec
ça permet aussi de rembourser
graduellement la dette le par le biais
du fonds des générations
donc le québec est dans une situation où
oui le ratio d'endettement du québec
presse quand même élevé par rapport à
certaines provinces mais il ya beaucoup
de progrès qui sont faits depuis
quelques années et ça a changé la
perception à la fois des ménages à la
fois des entreprises les décideurs
publics
donc tout ça fait en sorte que sa lane
une confiance les entreprises et des
ménages s'est nettement redressée depuis
2016 et
celles ci sont nettement supérieurs à ce
qu'on voit au canada dans ce cirque est
les finances publiques du québec se sont
améliorés alors que par exemple en
ontario c'est beaucoup plus difficile
donc avec des déficits budgétaires donc
c'est quand même un très différent et ça
amène un plus pour l'économie du québec
avec une marge de manoeuvre
supplémentaire bon alors on attend
toujours ses signes de ralentissement on
aura l'occasion faire le point avec vous
l'an prochain
merci beaucoup manager merci